rhaegar targaryen lay dead on the banks
of the Trident His Royal Army shattered
and in retreat the days of the Dragon
Kings were clearly numbered until that
moment it would have been foolish to
commit Casterly Rock to either the crown
or the rebellion what would our family
have to gain in supporting a raving
madman all in entering a crusade to but
Robert Baratheon on the Iron Throne but
chaos benefits no one
it was time for House Lannister to do
what it could to ensure a return of
peace and prosperity to the land i Tywin
Lannister brought 10,000 Lannister
troops to the gates of King's Landing in
order to bring the bloodshed to a quick
and decisive conclusion King Aerys had
been sending Ravens for months begging
for my support to end the uprising in a
way his pleas have been answered as I
had suspected Aerys opened the city
gates and welcomed my men our plan was
clear crush Aerys remaining bannermen
and removed the remnants of the royal
family as quickly and efficiently as
possible any alternative meant years of
further war and our fragmented Seven
Kingdoms our means were bloody but the
results speak for themselves
as for Aerys it is true he met his fate
at the hands of my son Aerys have kept
Jamie close during the rebellion
thinking himself clever in keeping my
son as a hostage should I decide to
pledge support to the rebel cause this
proved to be his greatest mistake for
when the time came Jamie did his duty as
a Lannister
and drove his sword into the mad Kings
back with that Robert Baratheon's crown
was secured the new king recognized our
role in his ascension to the throne just
as he recognized how useful the mic'd
and riches of Casterly Rock would be if
he wanted to keep it to that end I
offered my daughter Cersei as his Queen
and Aerys not spurn this same offer
years earlier perhaps things would have
worked out differently with Robert and
Cersei crowned as king and queen of the
Seven Kingdoms it was a new day the
dragon was vanquished and the Seven
Kingdoms would thereafter belong to the
stag and the lion